>>Christian Kurzke: All right. Welcome, everyone.
Thanks for coming over to our talk. We will
be talking about developing Android applications
for Google TV.
I'm really excited to see all of you here
come for our talk for Google TV. So we're
going to keep it very interactive today.
I'm Christian Kurzke. I am the developer advocate
for Android on Google TV.
>>Jason Bayer: And I'm Jason. I'm a software
engineer and tech lead on the Android side
of Google TV.
>>Christian Kurzke: Great.
So with that, we also are very fortunate to
have this session live-streamed online. So
for all of you who are watching from at home,
hopefully on your Google TV, lean back, ten-foot
experience.
Go to the URL on top of the slide. You can
submit questions. We will answer the questions
later in the Q&A session.
For the guys who are here in the audience
and everyone else, go scan the QR code. You
can give us feedback on the session. And you
know the drill with Speaker Meter. It's hopefully
not the first talk you're in.
So with that, what are we going to talk about?
At first, for a few of you who are not familiar
with Google TV yet, we're going to give a
quick overview of what Google TV is from a
developer's point of view, from a user's point
of view. And then we're diving right in and
we talk about how you can optimize your app,
how you can enable your app to actually show
up on Google TV. And then we talk a few of
the extra capabilities.
So, actually, just to get a feel of the audience,
how many of you are actually Android developers?
All right. I love it.
So you guys are already familiar with writing
Android apps. So after this talk, hopefully,
you will know how to get your Android apps
on a really big screen.
All right. Without further ado, here is a
little reminder, just for people who are old
enough to remember this in their households,
this is what phones used to look like.
And very short time later, if you think about
how long the phone has been around, within
the last decade, really, we have taken the
phone from a pretty boring device to an incredibly
smart communications device that runs applications.
And it's really -- it's not your grandma's
phone anymore.
So I'm sure somebody in the audience has still
one of those at home, good-old cathode an
ray tube, electron beams. Lots of really cool
physics but not so much smarts in it.
So today, we're going to show you how you
get from there to here.
So what is Google TV?
I know we announced it last year here at Google
I/O. And since then, we have shipped several
-- or not we. Our partners have shipped several
devices.
So Google TV is a software platform. It has
been integrated in televisions, in Blu-ray
players, and in stand-alone set-top boxes.
So those devices here are from Sony and from
Logitech. And for U.S. developers, really,
don't think about the physical device as much.
Think about it as a platform for developers
running Android, running Chrome.
So why are televisions actually really that
interesting for you as developers?
I know you all write for phones. And keep
in mind, if you look at the number of households
that actually have access to a computer or
to mobile devices, still more households in
the U.S. have TVs. A lot of households have
actually multiple TVs, three TVs, five TVs.
And over the next couple of years, those TVs
will get increasingly smarter.
So we expect, according to some studies, that
by 2014, more than one-third of the households
in the U.S. will have a smart TV, will be
connected to the Internet, and will be doing
a lot more than just watching shows.
>>Jason Bayer: So let's get right to it.
So what's coming to Google TV? If you missed
the keynote yesterday, Google TV this summer
is going to be updated with Honeycomb, Honeycomb
3.1. Some of the major features for you will
be that this is a fully compatible Android
device.
What that means is that all of the APIs that
you know and are familiar with are going to
work on a Google TV.
Google TV will also come with Android Market.
So users will be able to find, download, and
use all of your Android apps.
And, finally, all the retail devices are going
to come with ADB. So you can debug and install
your apps on retail devices.
Now, all of the currently existing Google
TVs out there will also get this update. So
Honeycomb, ADB, Market, will be available
on new and current devices.
Next, we're going to have an SDK add-on. So
with this, you'll be able to run the emulator
with Google TV. And we're also going to be
including some extra TV-specific functionality.
And we'll get into the details later in this
talk.
All right. So one of the major themes of Honeycomb
upgrade for users is going to be simplicity.
This is a screen shot of the home screen of
Google TV. You'll notice at the bottom that
there is application shortcuts that the user
has configured, access to all applications,
and then above that, there's the app widget
Canvas. So users can go and place app widgets
directly on the home screen here.
Now, if you know about the current version
of Google TV, for users, this is a lot simpler.
We've cut out a lot of the -- what we think
unnecessary features. And we really want to
get users directly to applications.
So for U.S. developers and for users, we think
this is a big improvement.
>>Christian Kurzke: And also, keep in mind,
it's probably not clear from the slide here,
but what you see through here is actually
live TV. So when a user presses the home button
on the remote control, they get the little
app launcher in the bottom. And then the rest
of the screen is live TV. And you as a developer
can overlay widgets over this.
So the good news is, as Android developers,
you already know how to create widgets. So
now, with Google TV, you can create widgets
that live in the living room on the largest
screen in the house. So you can get information
really quickly to your users.
>>Jason Bayer: Next, this is a screen shot
of the quick search box.
This is similar to what you see on phones,
tablets, and the current Google TV. But I
just want to point out how simple and easy
it is for users to search over contents. And
we make it really easy to highlight all of
the video results and TV results on the top.
And any application results show up in an
organized manner.
So this is just another good way to direct
users to your application.
>>Christian Kurzke: So this was a very brief
overview of what the team has been focused
on over the last year. So now let's look,
how can you as a developer optimize your application
to run on this device.
So for that, I brought a little screen shot
or a little photo of Jason's living room,
in case you guys have been over, he has really
eclectic taste. Love the red couch.
>>Jason Bayer: I'm going to check speaker
meter afterwards to see how good your jokes
are.
>>Christian Kurzke: So what I want to really
highlight with this slide is, the TV is a
very new interaction model for users. So as
a developer, you should really think of a
TV not just as a big phone. It's rather different
in a few subtle ways. It has a different input
device. So some of you may remember when TVs
did not have a remote control. You actually
had to get off the couch and change channels.
We don't want to get back to this where you
have to get off the couch and touch the screen
and press icons on the screen. So for that,
we have remote controls.
And then also, the TV screen, it's big, but
you sit pretty far away. And you're usually
in your living room. You want to relax. You
want to chill. You don't want to lean forward,
interact with a laptop.
So talking about input devices. So these are
the remote controls or the input devices for
Google TV today. You see the Sony and the
Logitech input device. First thing you will
notice is it has full QWERTY keyboard. So
it makes it very easy to enter text. If you
have search queries, if you go on the Web,
it's very easy to quickly enter text here.
The other thing you will notice is there is
extra buttons on this.
And I want to highlight this area of the keyboard.
So all of the Google TV devices have a five-way
navigation pad. We call it the D-Pad for directional
pad.
And it also has several media buttons for
fast forward, play, rewind, and so on.
We do have a mouse pad. So both the Sony and
the Logitech device have a mouse pad, which
emulates touch input. But the goal for a developer
should really be to optimize an application
to take advantage of the up, down, left, right
navigation. It's the way that is most intuitive
for people who are in the living room, and
it's also more convenient to actually do this
without having to look at the TV. You can
just very easily click up and down.
Also, the media keys. We already, -- by the
way, if you have looked carefully through
the Honeycomb key codes, there is already
key codes in Honeycomb today that map to the
play, pause, rewind, and so on. So in case
you were wondering, this is why we got them
into Honeycomb.
So when I say optimize your application for
D-Pad, what does that mean?
Okay. Take a look at this UI here. It's a
very simple tab view with a listview embedded
and maybe or a couple buttons at the bottom.
This is what your average application would
look like on a tablet. Think of your contacts
app or maybe an image gallery, and the user
can browse up and down through a list of items,
maybe click on a few items, mark them, and
then go to the button.
If you navigate this on a tablet with your
fingers, it's very intuitive.
If you navigate this with only the up, down,
left, right key, you will have to scroll through
all of the items in the listview all the way
to the bottom to get the focus to the button.
This is not very convenient for a user to
navigate on a D-Pad.
With a very simple change, you can improve
the usability of this for a D-Pad user.
Also keep in mind, naturally, TVs are landscape
devices, they are not portrait. So if you
have a listview, the list items usually tend
to be very long, and you should probably contain
them in multiple columns anyway.
So in this view here, we have three columns.
We have one column with a ListView for -- ListView
in the middle. We have tabs to the side and
the buttons to the other side. Now you can
very easily just navigate down, down, mark
a couple items, and then left or right. Switch
the tabs or hit the button.
A lot fewer key strokes for your users, and
a lot easier to navigate.
One other remark I want to make is over the
last couple of months we have been working
with a couple of the preload developers and
a couple of the early access guys, and taking
an existing Android application and running
it on TV, very frequently for a developer
you don't pay too much attention of where
the focus next and -- basically previous and
next focus of your elements are, because on
a touch screen, really you don't care as much.
The user can just randomly touch things on
the screen.
When you develop for TV and you optimize for
D-Pad, take a second look at your layouts
and make sure your elements are properly wired
so that the next focus really is what the
user expects.
>>Jason Bayer: There is actually a new attribute
in Honeycomb for a next focus forward because
we have a tab key. So when users hit tab on
the keyboard, it moves the focus forward and
shift-tab for back.
So if the system doesn't do what you expect
it to, you can override the next focus forward.
So we have the same problems with these layouts
on nontouch devices when you look at the action
bar.
If you were around for the last talk and paying
attention, you'll know that there is now an
API in Honeycomb to standardize the action
bar. This is supposed to standardize the app
navigation and highlight common actions. On
the tablet, this is up here at the top. But
you could imagine on a nontouch device if
you are navigating through a list in the body,
switching tabs ends up being pretty burdensome
using the D-Pad.
So on this note and considering what Christian
was just mentioning, we went ahead and used
the same exact action bar APIs, and we're
thinking of rendering this on the left side.
So you take a look at this action bar with
the same tabs and actions. From the user's
perspective, it would be very easy for them
to D-Pad over to access different tabs. And
from your perspective, you can use the exact
same action bar API, and depending on which
device it's running on, on a TV it will be
optimized for a nontouch and for a phone or
tablet it will render in a different layout
optimized for touch.
Okay. So next let's talk about the TV screen
itself.
>>Christian Kurzke: You know what this picture
actually needs? This picture needs a couple
socks.
[ Laughter ]
>>Christian Kurzke: I am working on my jokes.
Anyway, anyone want some Google TV socks?
[ Laughter ]
>>Jason Bayer: I think there's some people
in the back.
>>Christian Kurzke: All right. I have a few
more. Let's try this.
>>Jason Bayer: Ahh, it's the wind. Front row
seats.
>>Christian Kurzke: That's what you get for
being here early.
>>Jason Bayer: So this might look like a familiar
table to you, if you have been on developer.android.com.
This breaks down the dinner screen sizes,
there is a small, normal, large, extra large
screen and theirs there's also the different
densities, so low density, medium density,
high density, extra high density.
You can see the old G1. That's a normal screen
and medium density. The Motorola Xoom is an
extra large screen and medium density.
So any guesses as to where TV would fit into
this table? What kind of screen? What kind
of density? That (indicating)? Okay. I'm not
sure what that means.
>>Christian Kurzke: Socks for "that."
>>Jason Bayer: It turns out that TV is going
to be large screen and either high or extra
high density depending on the resolution.
Now, this may seem a little counterintuitive
or maybe surprising, considering how big a
TV screen is. And when you look at how many
dots per inch a TV has, it's actually quite
low. But there's actually a good reason for
it. This has a lot do with where users are
sitting. So on a TV, you think users might
be 5, 10, 15 feet away from the screen compared
to maybe one foot on a phone or tablet.
So really what matters is not the physical
density but the perceived density.
So we went ahead and calculated basically
the angular distance of a pixel, and in this
picture here you can see just on Christian's
phone, but you could kind of space it out,
you could see that, effectively, the density
is up to XHDPI on a 1080p resolution. This
is actually a good thing because when you
are using density independent pixels, the
same object you have on a phone or tablet
should look roughly the same size on a TV
to a user.
So this is all for good intentions.
So considering these density values, when
you do the math, our screen size turns out
to only be large. And when you think about
it, when you're on a tablet and it's an extra
large screen, there's quite a lot of space,
so you could put pretty complex UIs in there.
But given that we are a very high density
screen, the system is going to scale up your
assets more. So effectively, you have less
screen real estate to deal with.
>>Christian Kurzke: So here is a little bit
more. For the people of you who were trying
to keep track and keep notes of all the different
densities and everything, so here is an overview
of the resolutions and the screen sizes that
we came up for Google TV.
So the two main resolutions that we look at
is 720p and 1080p. Those are the names of
the two common HD screen sizes or screen resolutions.
And for those of how think in pixels, it's
basically 1280 by 720 pixels or 1920 by 1080
pixels.
After working on this team for about a year,
I dream in those numbers.
So....
Here is the dpi. So when we decided, we decided,
as Jason said, based on the distance you are
sitting from a TV. We did the math. We locked
in the 320 dpi's for 1080p resolution, and
it is much higher. If you walk up close and
actually count the pixels on your TV just
for fun you will find approximately 50 pixels
per inch on an average 40-inch television.
But when you view it from a distance, it looks
the same as if there was 320.
With that, if you know how Android does all
the resolution calculations, you have an effective
screen size of approximately 960 by 540 display
independent pixels, or DP's.
And for 720, we made sure that this virtual
resolution or the logical resolution stays
constant, and we adjusted the dpi's to 213,
you may be familiar with the regular scale.
Typically, other devices which have a high
density, they have 240. But 213 is close enough,
and for you as a developer, the advantages
with those two values, you can lay out your
elements the same for both 720 and 1080p.
So your layouts can stay the same for both
major screen resolutions.
And the screen size is large. It makes sense.
Most TVs come in, like, 30 inch, 40 inch,
50 inch. It doesn't matter which Hdpi resolution
you are running.
So with that, we came to basically to the
end results that it's a large screen with
XHdpi or Hdpi.
Okay.
It's too many Xs and Hs.
So with that, let's talk a little bit about
TV history again.
So one of the concepts that you may or may
not know from television is the concept of
overscan and scan lines. So back in the good
old days, when you had electron beams drawing
the image on your TV at home, the electron
beam would actually go a little bit over the
edges, because it didn't want black on the
sides so it's safer to overpaint a little
bit on the edges. So that's where the concept
of overscan came in.
So effectively, if you look at a large display
with the resolutions that we have talked about,
we have effectively a physically addressable
screen of 1920 by 1080 pixels. So that's what
the maximum output can be.
Now, modern TVs, even though they are all
digital and we all think in digital terms,
there is still the concept of overscan. And
this may be because of manufacturing tolerances
or maybe for optical reasons, the manufacturers
may have covered some of the sides with just
the aluminum bezel on your screen or maybe
there were some manufacturing reasons not
to have all the full pixels.
What we found is when we just look at real-world
TVs out there in the world, there is about
-- I want to say one-third of the TVs which
display close to the maximum, and the rest
displays anything up to 5% or 10% less resolution.
As a user, when you set up Google TV, you
calibrate the Google TV to your visual area.
After this, the set-top box, which since we
don't know which TV we are connecting to,
it's a stand-alone set-top box, but after
the calibration, we know what the visible
area is that you can expect. And Android,
after this, will do the math for you and it
will make sure that if you, for example, request
a full-screen Canvas, it will be only the
visible area. So you don't have to worry about
things getting clipped off on the edges. But
as a developer, you have to be cautious to
not make implicit assumptions about the resolution.
You can, when you do a full-screen Canvas,
you can get a resulting Canvas that may be
anywhere between the maximum resolution of
1920 down to something like 10%, 12% less.
So the worst-case scenario that we accounted
for is actually the numbers here. It's 1692
by 952.
So as a developer, when you write your app
and you run it on Google TVs out in the world,
just be prepared that those values sometimes
may change.
>>Jason Bayer: I don't think you really need
to know or understand about this overscan
history, but just don't assume that 1080p
on Google TV means you are going to get 1080
pixels. It may be somewhat less but as long
as you are programming for not caring about
resolution, then you should be good.
>>Christian Kurzke: And when you write your
app, try it out on different screen sizes.
So either calibrate your TV or we'll show
you later with emulators.
So the way you get around all this and what
it means for you as an Android developer,
it's already good coding practices to not
have absolute layouts, to not assume coordinate
sizes. So just use the regular Android mechanisms.
Things like relative layouts, linear layouts.
You can float elements on the screen, or you
can stretch certain UI elements. Whatever
makes sense for your UI.
>>Jason Bayer: And 9 patches are your friends.
>>Christian Kurzke: Oh, yeah. 9 patches, they
have been around for such a long time, and
we think that people would really be excited
about them, but unfortunately, very often
people still use hard coded just image buttons
or anything. So if you are not already using
9 patches, that's a great way to optimize
your application.
>>Jason Bayer: One other thing about the screen.
Maybe it's obvious, but you can't expect users
to reorient their screen from, like, landscape
to portrait when it's a TV.
[ Laughter ]
>>Jason Bayer: Given this, if you have an
activity that is basically locking into portrait
mode or at runtime you are trying to set request
an orientation to portrait, these really won't
look good on a TV.
So what you should do is just ensure that,
first of all, your app can function in landscape
environments and you should make sure it looks
good, too.
So just to recap. We think you can make a
really awesome looking Android app on a TV
screen if you understand what makes TV different.
Thinking about the input devices, we don't
have a touch screen but you should optimize
for D-Pad. And looking at the screen size
and density, you could provide different assets
and layouts and so on considering TV's attributes.
So given this, we think it really shouldn't
be a lot of work to take your app, your existing
app, and make it look good on TV.
>>Christian Kurzke: Okay. So now let's look
at a few examples from the real world.
So over the last couple months, if you have
used Google TV with the Pandora application,
I just want to highlight how the Pandora application
came about.
So if you look here, this is the Pandora mobile
application. I took a picture it have running
in landscape mode and it's a very clean layout.
It has the cover art, it has the artist information
and it has a few buttons on the bottom. You
touch them for pause, forward, and so on.
So what the Pandora team did is they actually
reused a lot of their layouts, a lot of their
-- I want to say branding, a lot of their
code also to create the Google TV application
that's preloaded on your Google TV today.
Obviously, it's running on Google TV in a
higher resolution, so they used higher album
cover art, but everything else is pretty much
the same. The only other difference is what
they added, they added support for the keypad.
So when you run your app, you can, on your
remote control, just use the pause, the forward,
the rewind button, and it makes it much easier
than trying to hit those buttons with like
an on-screen cursor.
Another example is the CNBC application. So
when this application was started, the CNBC
team looked at their mobile app, and we were
brainstorming how can we get the mobile app
to a great TV experience.
So here is the mobile app. It's just tracking
a portfolio of stocks. Gives you the gains,
losses.
And we also looked at the Web site, and the
Web site has a lot of in-depth information,
but we feel that on television, people want
something a little bit more interactive, a
little bit more visual.
If you really want to read the latest earnings
report, you most likely will do this either
on your desktop or if you want do it on TV,
you have a full Chrome browser. You can just
go to the Web site.
So the CNBC team, they decided to take, again,
large parts of their mobile application. Virtually
most of the server communication and the application
logic stayed the same. Since it's all in Android
on mobile already, they could just literally
use the same code. And on TV, they added a
more visual interface and they added actually
video clips. So now not only do you get the
news of your stocks, not only do you get the
daily earnings or losses, but you get video
clips.
So if you are following a few stocks you are
interested in, if you see the little video
symbol, you can just click on it and on Google
TV you will get a video clip of the latest
news report, analyst opinion about the stock
that you were interested in.
So now with that, how can you enable your
app to actually be available on Google TV?
And I think the first question you have to
ask yourself is do you really want to make
money? And I think most of you here will.
If you don't want to make money, let us know.
All right.
So with that, to make money you need a market.
So --
>>Jason Bayer: Right.
>>Christian Kurzke: Jason, talk about the
market.
>>Jason Bayer: So this is a screen shot of
market running on Google TV. It looks really
beautiful, it looks really nice. Despite the
fact that it looks a little bit different
from Android Market on your tablet, we really
shouldn't think of this as the TV market.
This is really Android Market. This just happens
to be on TV.
So all the developer tools, the publishing
system, analytics, that's all the same and
consistent with what you already know.
Before you put it on Google TV, you probably
want to make sure everything works well.
Well, what you could do right now is fire
up the Honeycomb emulator. There may be some
performance issues, but you can start the
Honeycomb emulator, set some of the attributes
to be for Google TV-like environments. So
like the TV resolution, the density. You are
going to have to change the VM heap a little
bit. But once you do this you can get pretty
much most of the way there. So you can see
how your app would look if it was on a Google
TV. You can try out the D-Pad navigation.
You can do all the optimizations we had talked
about already today.
What's going to come soon is we are going
to release the files you need to run a Google
TV in an emulator. The only real difference
with this compared to what you can do today
is any of the nuanced behavioral differences
that we are introducing. There are some skinning
and styles that are different, and there are
some additional APIs that we are going to
be telling you about.
>>Christian Kurzke: Things like the action
bar, for example. You can really see what
your app looks like with the new side action
bar, and it's a lot more accurate for TV.
>>Jason Bayer: Right. So right now you can
already get started and do most of your work
already, and pretty soon we will have a TV
emulator for you.
And then of course later this summer, when
we update all of the existing and new Google
TV devices with Honeycomb and ADB, then you
can run your app on the physical device.
And actually, if you don't want to wait that
long, we do have a special program for our
I/O attendants. So we have this thing called
the fish tank program. These are our development
boxes that we are using internally, and we
are going to be giving away some -- if you
stop by our Office Hours afterwards, it's
just right over here to the left, you can
pick up a flier and we will have more information
on how you can sign up and get one of these
boxes.
>>Christian Kurzke: Yeah, they didn't let
me throw them from the stage.
[ Laughter ]
>>Christian Kurzke: Our Office Hours are right
across the hallway here if you want to stop
by, you can pick up a flier and sign up.
>>Jason Bayer: Okay.
So let's say that you do want to optimize
your app for TV. What are the different mechanisms
you can use to accomplish that?
Well, if you want to go and optimize your
navigation, your look and feel based on our
screen sizes and our lack of touch, then what
you really should be using is the resources
directories. So you can specify based on what
it is you are optimizing for. Like, for example,
large screen, high density, and no touch,
or maybe you have extra high density, no touch
and landscape.
You could place different assets and layouts
in the different resource directories.
The nice thing about this is once you make
these changes for Google TV, these will affect
all the other devices that maybe aren't Google
TVs but have the same attributes.
So really, you fix it this one time and your
app will look good across lots of different
devices.
Another thing you could do is check for at
run-time presence of Google TV. So this is
really a special case so if it's Google TV,
do one thing; otherwise, do something else.
Obviously it's special treatment, but if that's
what you want to do, you can go ahead and
do that.
The way do you that is we have a special feature
in our system which is really just saying
this is Google TV. You could check at runtime
through the package manager. You could also
put this tag in your manifest. And of course
if you say that Google TV is required, then
your app will only show up on Google TV devices
and not on phones or tablets.
And finally, if you use the Google TV library
when it's available, then you could go ahead
and put this uses library tag in the manifest.
If do you this, then it will load up the Google
TV library which has some extra functionality.
And again, if you say it's required, then
your app will only work on Google TVs, although
you can say it is not required and then it
will still work on phones and tablets.
A little bit more about the features. Google
TV has different hardware features from maybe
what you are used to on phones or tablets.
This is a list of the features that our current
devices support.
We have -- Because we have this mouse, we
have what we calm emulated touch screen. It's
not a true touch screen because you are not
touching it but we can still send touch events.
So the feature itself is called fake touch.
We also have basic location and network location
support.
There is Wi-Fi on all of the boxes, and then
there is this special Google TV feature.
One thing to keep in mind is if you are using
permissions and you are requesting them, some
of them do implicitly require hardware features.
You could check the Android documentation
for the complete list, but just to be safe,
you should be explicit about which hardware
features you require and which ones you use
but you doesn't necessarily require.
So if you use telephony or a camera in your
application but you don't require it, you
can still show up on Google TV. You just have
to put in the line in your manifest saying
you use the camera but you don't require it.
>>Christian Kurzke: I just want to point out
since we have all the really great Android
developers here, keep in mind, the whole features
aspect, it's really important across all Android
devices, not just Google TV. We really want
your app to run on as many devices as possible.
So if your app, for example, uses, say, camera
autofocus but you can totally live without
any camera at all, maybe you just have a fall-back
and you load your photos from an SD card or
something, don't require the feature. Make
it required false. And then check at run time.
And at run time, depending on which device
you are running on, you can make a decision
and you can either show a fall-back or you
can enable the feature as intended. But this
will help you to get a broad reach.
And we want your app to run across all devices,
including Google TV.
>>Jason Bayer: A little bit more about the
touch screen capability.
So if you do nothing in your manifest, so
you don't specify anything at all about touch
screen, Market's going to go ahead and assume
that you need a real touch screen. This is
for some backwards compatibility reasons.
So what this means is, if you do nothing and
your manifest doesn't say anything, it won't
show up on Google TV.
In order to show up, you're going to have
to make a change to this.
One way to change it is, being if your app
needs some sort of touch screen but you determine
you're kind of okay with this fake version,
you know, it really depends on your app, if
you need someone actually pressing the screen
or if you're okay with this mouse or other
kind of fake touch.
If this is something that you're okay with,
then you just have to specify this in your
manifest, basically saying you don't require
a true touch screen, but you do require some
kind of fake touch. When you do this, actually,
all of the real touch screens will still be
considered fake touch. So when you do this,
basically, your app will still show up on
phones. It will still show up on tablets.
It will also still show up on Google TV.
The other option is if your app is fully D-Pad
friendly. So maybe you still support touch,
but someone can navigate your app and do everything
they need to just using a D-Pad. If this is
the case for your app, you can just simply
say you don't require a touch screen, and
then your app will show up on all the devices,
no matter what kind of touch screen, fake
touch, or no touch. So this is really the
simplest thing if your app is D-Pad friendly.
>>Christian Kurzke: So with that, one of the
other things to keep in mind is a few of the
features that if your app requires will actually
not make it show up on Google TV.
So as we announced before, currently, we will
not support native applications, native meaning,
you know, having native code libraries in
your app. So the NDK will not be supported.
And, initially, we also will not support things
like cameras, microphones, a lot of the sensors,
like a barometer in your TV probably makes
less sense than in a mobile device.
So this is for now, just to get you started.
We are working on enabling features as they
make sense over the future. So the team is
really focused on getting more support for
a lot of those features and also working with
the OEMs, whatever they can come up with.
But, you know, keep in mind, probably not
the accelerometer.
[ Laughter ]
>>Christian Kurzke: If your TV starts moving
and you're having an earthquake, then sorry,
no apps for that.
So here's just a very simple snippet. And
I think that's what a lot of people are interested.
If you want your app to show up on the Google
TV market, one of the easiest ways is just
make sure, for example, you have touch screen
set to false. For location, we do support
the basic location. When the user sets up
the Google TV, they typically enter their
ZIP code. So when you write on the application
something like a weather widget or anything
that needs course location, you're okay. But
we will not have a fine-grained GPS location.
The other thing we obviously will not have
is telephony. So if you set those to false,
your application -- and you don't require
any of the other features that are pretty
obvious, then your application will run on
-- or show up on Google TV market and run
on Google TV.
So now for those two of you earlier who don't
want to make a lot of money and actually don't
want to be on the Google TV market. And there
may also be other more logical reasons for
this. So say you are a software developer,
you have an incredibly successful app that's
in the market and you get reports from people
once market launches that, oh, my God, the
app breaks on Google TV.
We actually would really like to have only
awesome apps and a lot of awesome apps on
Google TV. We would love you to actually fix
the app. If you say, "Oh, my God, I don't
have time right now this week. There is finals.
I can't fix the app." Whatever.
[ Laughter ]
>>Christian Kurzke: Then you can opt out very
easily. Just want to re-emphasize, as Jason
said earlier, by default, we assume that your
app needs touch screen. If you set the "requires
touch screen" to true, then you will not show
up on the market for Google TV today. So that's
sort of a stopgap if you really don't want
to show up for a while.
So let's check out a few other cool features.
So now you've learned how you can optimize
an app, how you can get it ready for the market.
And Jason's going to talk about a couple extras
that we have in store for you.
>>Jason Bayer: Okay. So first, the Google
TV remote application.
As you might know, this is an app that we
released for iPhone and Android phones that
you can pair with and then control a Google
TV device. This is available right now. It
works on the current version of Google TV.
We've gotten a lot of feedback from users.
Some people really love this. But we know
there's a lot more that can be done with remote
applications.
So what are we going to do about this?
Well, as of today, we're going to go and release
the source code for this application under
the Apache 2 license.
[ Applause ]
>>Jason Bayer: So you can go to this link
today, right now, and you can see the source
code for this app and you can change it as
you would like.
When we look a little bit underneath to this,
there's two different parts to this. One is
actually doing the pairing between the remote
clients and the Google TV. And then once you
are paired, you can send key events, mouse
events, and URIs to the connected TV. So there's
kind of two subprojects to that. But these
are also being released under the Apache 2.0
license.
>>Christian Kurzke: If you want to see what
you can do with all of this, if you go over
to the Google TV sandbox just in the main
area, we have a couple TVs. And one of the
companies, Buddy TV, they actually use this
protocol to show a new version of the remote
control. They have integrated their mobile
app with the TV app using some parts of this
protocol.
>>Jason Bayer: Actually, I'm not sure they're
using this protocol. But it's still a really
cool application of remote and TV interaction.
>>Christian Kurzke: Okay. They're using I.P.
>>Jason Bayer: Okay.
So some more capabilities that we're opening
up.
So one of the things the user does when they
set up their Google TV, either through Dish
in two-way pairing, or they manually set which
provider they have, but we know about all
the channel listings that the user has for
TV channels. So what we're going to do at
first is have a content provider where in
your app, you can go and see what channels
are available to the user. So we'll reveal
some basic information about each channel.
But we're also going to include this URI.
So with the URI from your app, you can go
and view these URIs. And then the TV player
will pick this up and tune to that channel.
So with this, you can basically see all the
channels the user gets, and you can take the
user into TV at this particular channel.
We know there's a lot of interest and a lot
of other cool and interesting things we can
do with the TV feed. We're working on that.
We don't have anything more to announce right
now. But in the future, we plan to expose
a lot more TV functionality into an add-on
library.
>>Christian Kurzke: So to wrap up, let's just
look at what you can get started with today.
So we've shown you earlier, if you want to
emulate your application running on a TV-like
screen, you can do this right now using the
Honeycomb emulator that's just part of the
standard Android SDK.
You can also, with the open sourced I.P. remote
application, you can also create your own
mobile app, and you can talk to all the Google
TVs that are out in the field today. So the
protocol is already on the current devices,
so you don't have to wait for the next generation
to roll out.
Very soon, you will be able to emulate a Google
TV system on your desktop. And you will be
able to try out some of the new UI features.
You can see how your app will run on the system.
And later this summer, we will, as we announced,
push out the new version based on Honeycomb
to the devices. And you will have ADB on the
devices for developers. And, of course, you
will have Market available as well.
And as always, the team is really focused
and is working hard to get new TV APIs out
to you guys. So stay tuned. There is going
to be updates as we go along.
>>Jason Bayer: And one more thing. I think
we're all really excited that you came and
you're interested in developing for TV. And
this is a really exciting time, because we're
going to be enabling Market on TV for the
first time.
So we're really hopeful that you can help
this platform and we can help you and we can
get your help in really making your apps work
on TV. And I think there's a lot of really
awesome things we can do here.
>>Christian Kurzke: So, yeah, actually, the
QR code here, if you scan that, it's going
to take you to our developer site. It's google.com/TV.
And as I was walking up on the stage here,
I was promised that we will push it live somewhere
today. So if you're lucky, you may actually
already have it now. But within the next couple
hours. We already have the information for
Web developers. And so we will also put up
documentation for Android developers.
So you can actually get started and you didn't
have to take notes of all the cryptic numbers.
So that's all going to be on the documentation.
Also, as the other Android developers, we
will be on stack overflow. So if you run into
problems, you run into questions as you go
along and port your applications on Google
TV, you can find us on stack overflow.
I am really excited to have so many developers
who are going to create the next killer apps
for Google TV.
So with that, we can open up for questions.
If you went to the moderator page on the URL,
we can answer that. And we have two microphones
here in the room.
So I'm just going to pull up the moderator.
>>Jason Bayer: Okay.
[ Applause ]
>>Christian Kurzke: All right. How about let's
start with a live question from the audience.
>>> I'm a non-U.S. developer. And I was wondering,
is there a program for international developers
who want to add Google TV support to their
applications or is Google looking to only
support U.S. developers at the moment?
>>Christian Kurzke: So the -- currently, the
program is very much focused on bringing the
retail devices to U.S. users. Once the Android
Market is open, developers from all over the
world can theoretically publish applications
that are available on Google TV devices.
>>> Sure. But there are problems with the
emulator as I'm sure most Android developers
will tell you, specifically, with Honeycomb.
So getting hold of the hardware is pretty
important to international developers who
want to be add Google TV support. So is there
going to be a mechanism or a way we can do
it or are we going to kind of be locked out?
>>Christian Kurzke: So for right now, we don't
have a good way -- I would encourage you to
talk with some of our business guys over in
the office hours on the sandbox.
But the Fish Tank program that we announced
is only for U.S.-based developers right now.
>>> Okay.
>>Jason Bayer: Should we take one from moderator.
So the question is, can notifications be shown
automatically on top of live TV?
Well, I think the answer is yes, they can.
>>Christian Kurzke: So just using the regular
Android modifications API, they will show
up on top of the live television.
So from the second microphone back there.
>>> You talked about the list of channels
that you're going to get, I mean, have a whole
list of URIs that allows you to switch to
a particular channel.
Is there going to be a public list of all
of those URIs somewhere so that we can do
mappings our self?
>>Jason Bayer: That's definitely something
we are going to work on. But I don't think
that will be ready in summertime. But stay
tuned.
>>> Okay.
>>Christian Kurzke: Let's take another live
question from the audience.
>>> With the Market release, will there be
support for AdSense or AdMob, any ad monetization
mechanisms?
>>Jason Bayer: Well, we still are Android,
and we're a compatible Android device. So
I would expect all the Android APIs that we
use to still work. As for AdMob in particular,
I'm not sure. I haven't actually seen how
it looks.
>>Christian Kurzke: So I have been told that
since AdMob is based basically on just regular
Android, it will work on those applications.
Let's take an online question.
So the current Google TV has Chrome browser.
Honeycomb does not. What will the 3.1 update
mean for Chrome browser on Google TV?
Another excellent question.
So don't worry, all of our Web developers.
Google Chrome will be on the 3.1 release.
So you will still have the full Web browsing
experience on the device as well.
How about a live question, second mike.
>>> First I want to say I'm grateful for being
part of the device seeding program for the
review. And I don't want to sound ungrateful,
but I found it turned out to be completely
useless for me on a daily basis because it
doesn't pass through 3D. And it seemed really
odd that they would choose to do that in such
a modern, high-tech device.
Is there going to be any push from Google
to make sure that vendors are supporting that
so that it doesn't get pushed out where other
technology is maybe taking priority?
>>Jason Bayer: We're definitely working with
OEMs to try to -- well, basically have more
variety of hardware. So there is both more
advanced hardware and there's also cheaper
hardware.
So we are working closely with all of our
partners to try to have, basically, a better
variety of hardware choices.
>>> Is that something that's being talked
about? I mean, a point that someone's aware
of?
>>Jason Bayer: I believe so.
>>Christian Kurzke: I will bring this back
to our OEM group, who is working. I can't
make any promises. But I'll definitely let
them know that this is a frequent request.
>>> Thank you very much.
>>> (off mike).
>>> Great. Glad to hear that.
>>Christian Kurzke: So just for the audience,
so our PM just said we're working on 3D support.
It's on the road map. It's coming.
Gentleman from the first --
>>> I work for the mobile phone company, and
I just want to ask you about if any risk to
transfer the mobile phone to TV. In coding
-- in (inaudible).
>>Christian Kurzke: So the question was if
you can port your existing Android application
to Google TV?
>>> Yeah.
>>Christian Kurzke: Yes.
>>> It would be the hardware and software.
>>Christian Kurzke: So including -- So for
-- you mean for video decoders, there is support
--
>>> No, no.
>>Christian Kurzke: Oh, okay.
>>> (inaudible).
>>Christian Kurzke: Okay. Maybe we should
talk about it later. I think definitely it's
both a compatible Android platform, so it
should be fairly easy to port applications.
So, yeah, you can find me -- I'll be over
at the office hours later, also for everyone
else.
>>> Okay. Thank you.
>>Christian Kurzke: Thank you.
>>Jason Bayer: So the question online.
So with the new update to Honeycomb, users
will be able to use Xbox 360 and PlayStation
controllers.
Will Google TV also have this capability?
Well, Google TV does have USB host mode. So
I would expect accessories to be able to plug
into Google TV devices and use them.
I haven't specifically tested Xbox 360 or
PlayStation controller, so I can't say for
sure about that. But you can plug in some
accessories and use them. We'll definitely
look into this, because it is an exciting
opportunity.
>>Christian Kurzke: Yeah. And it makes our
life easier that we already have the host
port. So some of the problems that the mobile
guys had are much easier for us, actually.
So let's take a question from the second microphone.
>>> Is there a time line for camera support?
I mean, it practically screams video conferencing
in your face.
>>Jason Bayer: Yep, it is something we know
about and are working on. There's a few different
factors involved for getting it to work.
One of the main ones is that, basically, to
change the hardware features on an Android
device, it basically doesn't let you dynamically
change that. So we are looking forward to
in a future Android version to be able to
basically plug in new hardware and remove
hardware. There's some marketing filtering
issues and other issues. So we're aware of
this limitation and we're working on it. No
specific time line.
>>> Okay. Thanks.
>>> What's the outlook for getting more Google
TV devices out there?
>>Christian Kurzke: We are working with our
OEM partners right now, so we just signed
up two new OEMs, Samsung and Vizio. So we
are really excited for getting devices out.
And as you know, with Android, since it is
an open platform, the adoption is probably
going to take off similar as on the phones.
I mean, the phones, we also saw the first
year was a little bit slow. Once the critical
mass -- I think what I'm really excited about
is all the developers, all the applications
-- the adoption will also take up.
>>Jason Bayer: Question online.
So the TV is much more a shared device, and
quick access to different accounts and settings
for different users is a potentially critical
feature. Is there any plan for supporting
multiple user profiles?
I can say yes, there is a plan. We're not
going to have very good support in the initial
update to Honeycomb. But this is definitely
on the road map. And I guess there is a few
things. There is switching users, and then
there is multiple users at the same time.
Even without full support from Android, I
think there's a lot of really interesting
applications to take advantage of the fact
that you're in a shared environment. So some
of the games and other things you can do on
the platform, knowing that there could be
four people or three people on at the same
time. There could be some really interesting
ideas for applications based on this.
>>Christian Kurzke: Okay. One more question
from the back.
>>> Apologize if you already addressed this.
But you had mentioned about hardware -- you
know, new hardware that's going to be coming
out and evolve. What's the time frame for
that hardware and what's the changes?
>>Jason Bayer: I don't think we have any specific
details about when hardware -- when new hardware
is coming out.
We're definitely working with a bunch of different
partners to come out with various varieties
of hardware. But no specific time lines on
that.
>>> Will it be this year?
>>Jason Bayer: No specific time lines on that.
>>Christian Kurzke: Yeah.
>>> (off mike).
>>Jason Bayer: So PM said we'll see announcements
later this year.
[ Laughter ]
>>Jason Bayer: All right.
>>Christian Kurzke: We're safe.
So we have 30 more seconds.
So let's take one more live question from
the front.
>>> Sure.
With your adoption of 3.1, are you going to
be supporting HTTP live streaming and the
adaptive component of live streaming for any
content consumption on the device?
>>Christian Kurzke: That's a very frequent
request. We know that developers would really
like that. We're working on it. So I can't
make clear yes or no promise. I don't want
you to, you know, hold me to that later. But
we're working on it and we're expecting this
to work.
>>Jason Bayer: Okay. So we're out of time.
So thank you very much for coming by. And
stop by our office hours.
[ Applause ]